did you see that viral video yesterday
of the little boy crying about being
bullied and the heartwarming outpouring
of support for him on social media did
you saw that was so nice
well it's ruined we will analyse why our
culture of insta Fame and slacktivism
means that we just can't have nice
things
then Arielle Davidson and Amber Athey
joined the panel of deplorable z-- to
talk Jimmy Kimmel slanderous
exploitation of his own son a lot of
children being exploited today Sarah
Huckabee Sanders smacking around fake
news and senator Elizabeth Warren lieth
is calling her Senate colleague Kirsten
Gillibrand a [ __ ] I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
that was fast that was a real fast news
cycle yesterday you saw this little kid
Keaton Jones this video goes viral but
the instant culture has now taken what
used to be fifteen minutes of fame is
now 15 seconds of thing before we love
somebody and then we just have to
destroy that person and move on to the
next whatever it is now before we get
into this today there is so much good
stuff to talk about but before we get
into it we have to talk about man crates
this is Christmas coming early as far as
I'm concerned I have been doing this
show just so that man crates would send
me a package that I can try out I got
very envious when Andrew Clavin opened
up his and they have really cool gift so
you know Christmas shopping holiday
shopping is very difficult especially
for guys you don't know exactly what
they want man crates dot-com makes it
very easy this is not a cheese of the
Month Club or the regular tie that you
get wrapped in the same box
man crates offers 100 hand curated gift
collections for every type of guy from
the rugged outdoorsman that's me I'm one
of those really rugged outdoorsmen you
know to these sports fanatic that's
alright to everything in between I fall
in the in-between with this I'm not very
rugged you know and I'm not a huge
sports fanatic but luckily for me they
have the whiskey appreciation crate with
personalized decanter and glasses for
your favorite drink that would be
whiskey by the way there's the
grillmaster crate with a brass knuckle
meat tenderizer love it man greats calm
you can pick the perfect crate that you
want and choose your delivery date when
the crate arrives the way that you will
open it is with a crowbar
that's your name laser engraved on it so
makes it really easy if you if you want
it gift-wrapped we know Christmas is
around the corner if you want a
gift-wrapped they will just wrap the
whole thing in duct tape for you so you
have to open up the duct tape and then
pry this thing open with a crowbar both
men's health and Allure magazine are
saying that man crates are the perfect
gift for men
those two magazines do not agree on very
much they do agree on this and so do I
they have thousands of five-star reviews
every man crate comes with a high-five
guarantee own the holidays
that now if you go to man crates dot-com
slash Knowles that's Keo wles like
Beyonce you'll get five percent off of
your order they don't offer this
discount anywhere else so it's five
percent off man crates dot-com /k nowl
es now if you don't want to get them to
create of these great grades if you say
no that I don't know that's too personal
then you can get the regular old generic
gift which is the gift card everyone
gives gift cards but man crates makes it
much much better because if you get them
a gift card they will put it into a
block of cement
they will then give you a sledgehammer
and you have to you have to smack the
cement until the gift card comes down I
think it is just fabulous so check it
out man crates calm slash Knowles and
you will own the holidays okay let's get
into news for those of you who didn't
see if this is Keaton Jones and the
viral video that we're all so yesterday
why why finding a way to make do okay
now this is on the one hand it's
heartbreaking to watch this little kid
crying about being bullied obviously
there's something I think in all of us
that just hates bullies there's bullies
are just the the worst we we know we
feel righteous anger toward them
sometimes people don't understand when
they're being the ones being bullied so
all these people on the left or saying
yeah stand up to bullies and by the way
if you don't want to do exactly what I
say I'm gonna shut down your business or
I'm gonna shut down your cake shop or
I'm gonna shut down your your florist
shop but it's heartbreaking it's
heartwarming it's not exactly Man Bites
Dog
you know kids get bullied all the time
that's that's a fact of elementary
school in middle school it isn't going
to change I don't think but okay that's
fine it's very nice as a result of this
video going viral every single celebrity
on earth I believe responded to offer
support so snoop diggity Doo dat tweeted
say little man you got a friend in me
for life hit me on DM so we can chop it
up love is the only way to beat hate
very nice the UFC says hey Keaton Jones
you have friends here at the UFC buddy
today and always
stand with Keaton then Donald J Trump
jr. said this boy is incredibly brave
and the video really got me Dana White
if he takes you up on your offer to see
UFC headquarters I would be honored to
host him and his family at our place if
they need somewhere to stay
Chris Evans stay strong Keaton don't let
them make you turn cold I promise it
gets better
while those Punk's at your school are
deciding what kind of people they want
to be how would you and your mom like to
come to the Avengers premiere in LA next
year that's pretty nice that sounds
pretty good Katy Perry says this broke
my heart today please be kind to one
another
Mark Ruffalo little buddy I was bullied
as a kid you're right it gets better you
are my personal superhero you got a pal
in the Hulk Monica Lewinsky said Keaton
I'm so sorry you're being treated this
way you don't deserve an ounce of pain
they'd be lucky to be friends with you
it gets better I'm not going to make any
jokes about that obviously there are
many Ryan Seacrest said Keaton Jones
your curiosity and kindness will
overcome this moment and bring you many
better days to come Enrique Iglesias
heartbreaking to see this keaton you're
strong to say these things and care so
much for others team Keaton I can't go I
mean obviously I was a lot there are
like hundreds more there's so many of
these so it was a little strange it was
a little strange that every single
person with a blue checkmark started
tweeting I'd send out a little tweet
about being bullied I think everybody
feels some empathy bit for this because
everyone gets bullied and most people
bully too and that's just a fact of
being elementary school and middle
school we have seen this viral culture
before it looks like it's accelerating
though someone started a GoFundMe
campaign that's where you you crowd
crowd fund you raise money online they
started a GoFundMe for this kid it
raised fifty five thousand dollars I for
what what what are they raising the
money for I don't know what what is the
kid gonna spend fifty five thousand
dollars on he's like nine years old or
something but they fund it because we
just feel we feel bad for the kid we
what can I do I can give him money
I can click I can hashtag that's all
that's all that we can do I don't even
know if the kid's gonna get money I
don't think the guy is connected to his
family so anyway it's a little weird but
it's clearly self-indulgent
whatever it's nice who cares but of
course we had to destroy it we had to
destroy this poor kid so they found a
photo all of these internet people found
a photo of Keaton's mother standing next
to a Confederate flag one or two photos
of this he's a kid from Tennessee there
were Confederate flags around so the
left pounced tarik nasheed I actually
couldn't see this tweet because he
blocked me one time I tweeted his own
words at him and he blocked me for it
but I did see this in news coverage to
reconize she'd who I'm not convinced
isn't just a right-wing troll by the way
but anyway prominent lefty treat me she
says that viral video of Keaton Jones
talking about being bullied is
heartbreaking
and I feel sympathetic toward that child
but his mom Kimberly on the other hand
is a suspected racist who makes a very
problematic posts bullying black
protestors didn't make problematic posts
she was standing next to a Confederate
flag people interpret that however they
like but she wasn't bullying people
she's I don't know what it means to be a
suspected racist I know we've got you're
under investigation
Bob Muller has been appointed to see if
you're you're really a racist I doesn't
mean a whole lot but anyway the more
lefties pounced on this it is the brutal
consequence of social media culture and
slacktivism we just need more clicks so
you know when you when you post
something on Facebook or Twitter
you do get a dopamine rush you think oh
well people like this oh I got a light
great oh I'll get another one get
another retweet and and those highs and
those lows have to go more quickly and
more quickly and they have to be more
extreme and more extreme so what used to
be a very long news cycle has now become
a 24-hour news cycle has now become an 8
hour news cycle and it all switches over
at cuts both ways to the mother
exploited her child and put him on the
internet and made him go viral and
people are at now exploiting this child
further because we have to talk about it
it's a cultural event it's a it's a
sympathetic story but then we need a
villain we need somebody to tear down
that this story was too nice without it
they did this to ken bone I don't know
if you remember ken bone back during the
2016 presidential debates
there was a nice-looking man and a red
sweater with a moustache and he became
an instant celebrity here's Ken bone
what steps will your energy policy take
to meet our energy needs while at the
same time remaining
environmentally-friendly
and minimizing job loss for fossil power
plant workers so he became a meme
because he just looks sort of silly he
looks like a cartoon character so they
really liked him he's so respectful
during the debate yes a serious question
he looked hopeful and so anyway he
became instafamous after he appeared on
television with the candidates but but
it was too nice we can't have that what
that bat-cycle gets old after a day or
two so now we have to make him into a
villain someone on reddit found out that
he had committed two egregious crimes
one he had looked at the widely
published naked photos of Jennifer
Lawrence and that I think that makes him
the only man in America to ever look at
the completely ubiquitous nude photos of
one of the most beautiful and famous
celebrities in the world I think it's
really off it's unbelievable that they
would let that man back out in public so
he did that and also he posted something
on reddit and said that perhaps it
wasn't murder for George Zimmerman to
kill Trayvon Martin perhaps it was in
self-defense some of the evidence showed
that perfectly reasonable and so he
became a villain and his reputation was
destroyed just as quickly as his fame
came about former Facebook executives
have been admitting just this effect
this came out today former Facebook
vice-president for a user growth Chamath
poly hot bhatia I'm sure I butchered
that said he feels quote tremendous
guilt for creating tools that are
ripping apart the social fabric of how
society works he went on quote the
short-term dopamine driven feedback
loops that we have created are
destroying how society works no civil
discourse no cooperation misinformation
miss truth this is not about Russian ads
this is a global problem it is eroding
the core foundations of how people
behave by in between each other
Facebook's founding president Sean
Parker criticized the company the same
way he said it quote exploits a
vulnerability in human psychology by
creating a social validation feedback
loop
to discuss that and much more we will
have to bring on our panel of deplorable
z-- but first before we bring on our
panel don't forget our third episode of
the conversation is coming today at 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
featuring the one and only big boss man
himself Ben Shapiro Fox News power
Player of the Week subscribe today to be
a part of the conversation and ask Ben
live questions which he will answer for
everyone to hear the episode of the
conversation will stream live on the Ben
Shapiro Facebook page and the Daily wire
YouTube channel it will be free for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
can ask the questions many are called
but few are chosen to ask questions as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire.com
head over to the conversation page to
watch the live stream after that just
start typing into the daily wired chat
box where Ben will answer questions in
the order they're entered into the live
feed for an hour so subscribe you have
to do it go over there and subscribe get
your questions answered by Ben Shapiro
today at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation
ok now to our panel we have from the
Federalist Ariel Davidson and we have
from the Daily Caller
amber Athey and all-female panel of
deplorable z-- Thank You Lord
Ariel social media allows conservatives
to crack the mainstream media monopoly
on information and get their views out
there isn't that a good thing I think so
yes what happens is social media tends
to turn people into keyboard warriors
and so I think there's a sense of
boldness that can sometimes be helpful
but more often than not can be extremely
inflammatory so I think there is a
give-and-take when it comes to social
media it's definitely been a way for
people to exit their bubble but it's
also been a way for people to reinforce
their bubble you know now that you can
share in your blockless on twitter or
you can also do some facebook choose
friend someone or to unfriend them be
somebody really close I think it does
sort of reinforce our perception of a
worldview which is why you know when
Donald Trump was elected there was sort
of a collective meltdown on the left and
I think a lot of that was because social
media had created this false sense of
how where political opinions lie in the
world you know and that can be somewhat
dangerous so I think in some ways social
media can
do more harm than good especially when
it's used to sort of bolster again these
keyboard warriors and people that take
to Facebook and Twitter to get their
political anger out instead of having a
face-to-face conversation there is that
aspect the unfriending phenomenon is
really strange to me there have been
another number of studies that show that
people on the Left are much more likely
to unfriend or disconnect from you on
social media if you're a conservative
than vice-versa than conservatives doing
it to lefties and I think the reason for
that is because lefties have never heard
anybody contradict their opinions they
preach tolerance and diversity and
they're shocked to find out that anybody
disagrees with them but for the other
aspect of that is that we are not we're
more than our political opinions people
are more than our political opinions so
if you sit and have dinner with somebody
and you find out they voted for crooked
Hillary that dirty rotten felon and my
third cousin if I saw that on Facebook I
might just ignore that person or look
away or unfriend them or something
but in person you have to talk to them
and it might be interesting different
perspectives make the world much more
beautiful they make the world more
interesting and they help you think
about what you really believe a lot of
that kind of disappears on social media
that said CNN would not give me a show
CNN is never going to give me a show and
if if these new media didn't exist we
wouldn't have a platform now amber if
social media have made our culture
faster more knee-jerk more hysterical is
there any way back from here or or we
just headed for even tighter news cycles
oh gosh that's a really hard question um
I don't see it really getting that much
better I hate to be a pessimist but the
more that I've been on social media it
seems like the more angry people get the
more political they get I remember being
on Facebook back in high school and it
was just about sharing prom pictures and
you know posting cat gifs and now it's
like everybody is sharing a political
opinion it's all about getting those
imaginary points from your friends or
your followers everybody on Twitter is
seeing who is the next person that I can
drag and then within 24 hours they're on
to the next evil villain like we saw in
the Keaton case
so it's definitely really dangerous that
I think it's great that more people have
a platform to express themselves in ways
that they couldn't before but as
Marielle was saying at the same time it
can really bolster sort of a almost
bullying where people are constantly
able to attack anybody that they want
any time and it really piles on when
there's so many other people who are
there to join in on the crusade and it's
obviously been formulated it's been
meticulously arranged these technology
so that you will keep going back and
you'll keep clicking and you'll keep
tweeting and you'll keep piling on
whoever it that aspect on psychologies
is probably not very healthy but the
effect on politics seems to be quite
healthy
could you imagine a world in which we
had an administration like president
Trump's excellent conservative policy
legislation of nominations cultural
battles from the NFL to political
correctness to the news media could you
ever imagine that without Twitter Donald
Trump's appeal his great strength is is
with Twitter it may be the case that it
has bad psychological effects but
politically I'm I'm not I'm not sick and
tired of winning yet I'm not try to
convince me that I am won't happen okay
we have more shameless exploitation of
children to get to with Jimmy Kimmel
we've got to talk about the [ __ ] shaming
shaming the [ __ ] [ __ ] shaming I don't
know one of those between laia Wafaa and
kirsten gillibrand but if you don't
subscribe to The Daily wire we can't
make that happen sorry folks if you go
to daily wire.com right now you can
subscribe it's $10 a month or $100 for
an annual membership and you will get me
you'll get the inter Clavin show you got
the Ben Shapiro show you can submit
questions to the conversation forget all
of that none of that matters this is the
thing guys
the leftist tears tumblr I drink I drink
many
beverages out of it I drink coffee tea
obviously I pour whiskey in my morning
coffee but what is really suited for
those salty and delicious left is tears
that you see around you all day and
every day during the Trump
administration so make sure you go over
there right now you can have them hot or
cold always salty and delicious we'll be
right back
[Music]
speaking of the shameless exploitation
of children here is Jimmy Kimmel
parading his six son around to make an
inaccurate political point they each
gave a full day of their very busy lives
to give me time off and I'm grateful to
them for doing that
and daddy cries on TV but Billy doesn't
I don't know what could be more
disgusting than putting a tax cut that
mostly goes to rich people ahead of the
lives of children why has it chipped and
funded already if these were potato
chips they were taking away from us we
would be marching on Washington with
pitchforks and spears right now when was
the last time the Jimmy Kimmel didn't
cry during a comedy monologue do we
remember was that lay was like 2008 or
something that every day now it seems
he's constantly shoving his politics
down our throat amber
whatever happened to Johnny Carson or
Jay Leno or entertainers forcing their
politics down our throats because
they're hacks or is it because we now
demand politics in our entertainment I
think it's a bit of both Act actually I
think in many ways
Donald Trump has sort of brought the
politics out of people who would
normally be non-political because a lot
of these people say Donald Trump is just
the worst thing that happened to America
ever so we all have to share our
political views now because we're in
this unprecedented state of politics at
the same time though we do have to
remember that we probably wouldn't be
talking about Jimmy Kimmel show if he
weren't parading his son around onstage
in this disgusting manner so it has been
helping their views to some extent he's
gotten a disgusting amount of YouTube
views on all these clips of him crying
about health care and it's kind of easy
Hollywood friendship and political
points for them to be constantly
attacking Republicans and Donald Trump
you're absolutely right we would not
talk about Jimmy Kimmel he hasn't been
funny in a while he used to be sort of
funny and now he's become this political
hack so he's got to up the ante turn it
up to 11 and literally parade his six
son all over television so that we will
talk about him eriell the premise of his
tirade is wrong
chip is funded it will continue to be
funded Republicans voted to fund it last
week the Children's Health Insurance
Program will be funded doesn't matter
that the premise is complete nonsense
does it matter to his audience or to the
political discourse well it's
interesting because Democrats actually
are the ones are voting against we're
doing the funding if I remember
correctly well they're upset they're the
Republicans wanted to get the funding
from so in my mind not even just
incorrect it's actually humanizing the
wrong party so if you want to you know
throw daggers throwing daggers the
Democrats in this situation but
regardless I think that the issue I have
asserted this form of grandstanding
that's been taking place and you kind of
we just talked about this in Prior
podcast but there's sort of a sense of
notoriety and fame has now become
associated with attacking Trump
attacking Trump and the GOP whether I
don't know how long that gravy train is
going to last but that seems to be sort
of the prerogative of a lot of
entertainers who see their ratings
falling and that can also apply to both
entertainers and politicians at least as
we've seen I think I was trying to fall
in the camps that a lot of Jeff lakes
sort of trying to reinvigorate please
popularity is through condemning Trump
but anyway we can talk about that
another time but I do think that this is
like amber said it's it's highly
inappropriate but just should go to show
that people appreciate or maybe they
don't appreciate everything's become
politicized now I would say it's not
even I think it's the politics this area
and I think that there are a lot of
people who feel like they know
everything they need to know by just
watching Jimmy Kimmel or John Oliver and
seemed no 140 character tweet you know
understanding the process of chip and
how it gets how funding gets accrued it
takes a little bit more it takes a
little bit more effort and I just don't
see that taking place and sort of our
soundbite driven social media and it
doesn't fit into a 140 character it
doesn't fit into 280 characters chip is
a it's a federal program if federal
programs require funding from certain
places and the way that that legislation
is made is like
way that sausage is made but how many of
these people who are harping on it how
many people like Jimmy Kimmel could
explain to you what chip is how it was
how it became a federal program where
the funding comes from how the funding
is spent and how much money is wasted it
seems to me very few of them right well
I think there's an element like I said I
think hysteria is what drives a lot of a
political dialogue and is especially
coming from the Democrats it's a
politics of fear you know how many times
you can hear with the tax bill that
millions are going to die how many do we
hear when you know Republicans were
advocating for repealing the individual
mandate for Obamacare how many times
have you hear the Concord say millions
are going to die I mean this is their
cross Achra spawns to nearly every
policy decision what makes Jimmy Kimmel
indifferent is that he's he's advocating
for or he's presenting a position that
didn't exist on the GOP side so he's
still saying that GOP decisions
basically no matter what the GOP does
millions are going to die that's pretty
much become the narrative of the left no
that's because Trump is literally Hitler
that makes sense there's a there's a
perfect parallelism makes sense to me we
have to move on to my favorite story of
the day this I woke up to this story I
just popped right out of bed I was so
happy to see it senator Elizabeth Warren
chief laia Wafaa responded to a trump
tweet by calling her Democrat Senate
colleague Kirsten Gillibrand a [ __ ] so
Donald Trump for his tweeted quote
lightweight senator Kirsten Gillibrand a
total flunky for Chuck Schumer and
someone who would come to my office
begging for campaign contributions not
so long ago and would do anything for
them is now in the ring fighting against
Trump very disloyal to Bill and crooked
used
I didn't say crooked Hillary anymore
just crooked they were billing crooked
and so senator Warren decided to respond
by by calling her colleague a [ __ ] so
she responded quote are you really
trying to bully intimidate and
slut-shame senator Gillibrand do you
know who you're picking a fight with
good luck with that Donald Trump
nevertheless she persisted
it's on that response is unbelievable
but Arielle first is it fair to say the
premise of Senator lieth of Foca Hondas
his tweet is that Donald Trump called
Kirsten Gillibrand a [ __ ] did he do that
he did it anything to get campaign
donations now you perfect that as a
sexual no no that's on you I think
Donald Trump has done after many
different people for a long the
sentencing lines who say that they're
eager and they're begging for donations
so that's not unusual for Donald Trump I
think that again this urn appeals to the
mass hysteria what's more disturbing to
me is that you know Elizabeth Warren and
suggesting her colleague is a [ __ ] and
that Trump is shaming her for it dary
how dare anyone slit a shame you for
being a [ __ ]
I don't think it was the Warren knows
what slut-shaming means I would I was
surprised that's the word she chose to
use sort of capture Donald Trump's
criticism but Amer I probably have you
probably been following this warrants
better than I have in Kris their
responses well it's amazing the reaction
because a Donald Trump knows what he's
doing he knows what he's especially with
these tweets he is the true he is the
poet of tweeting he is the William
Shakespeare of tweeting so he knows when
he says something she would do anything
he knows how the left is going to
respond now obviously saying that you
will prioritize that a Democrat or a
politician will prioritize donors over
the American people and constituents
that's the oldest political attack there
is Donald Trump rode that line of attack
all the way to the White House he said I
can't be bought by everybody everybody
else has bought and paid for by donors
but he knew that they would respond that
way and they can't resist from doing it
they have to put their heads right in
the gutter and then he can stand there
and say what's the matter with you I'm
saying
a typical timeless political insult and
you're bringing it right
to sex you dirty mainstream media
perverts now amber Liz Warren alleged
that he called Gillibrand a [ __ ] but she
didn't attack him for calling her a [ __ ]
she attacked him for suggesting that
it's bad to be a [ __ ] has the sexual
revolution advanced so much that the
left can no longer take offense at being
called a [ __ ]
when you you simply have to accept that
premise and then say that that's not a
bad thing well yeah it's it's so strange
the way that she chose to attack the
Trump suite a normal person if he if
they really thought that Trump was
making some kind of sexual innuendo I
would imagine they would throw up their
hands and they would say how dare you
accuse my colleague of you know wanting
to use sexual failures to get campaign
contributions she would never do that
that's disgusting it's unethical
instead Elizabeth Warren's response was
that even if senator Gillibrand had done
that then shame on you for criticizing
her it's not that she would have that
she would never do that it's that even
if she did you're wrong for calling her
a [ __ ] for doing it it's so absurd I
mean if that really is the case that she
did that and I don't even think that's
what Trump was implying because he's
used the same language about senator Ted
Cruz for example he said to MIT Romney
said MIT Romney came begging for my
endorsement I could have told him to get
on his knees was he sexually harassing
Romney apparently so it's it's so funny
that you know even if that's what Trump
was implying for them to take issue with
the fact that he was calling her a [ __ ]
rather than that he was accusing her of
doing something unethical is just
indicative of how politically correct
the left is and Elizabeth Warren's
clearly trying to play into the young
millennial SlutWalk modern feminism ploy
where women are allowed to do whatever
they want and they can't be criticized
for it because you're just such shaming
or being sexist so I think this is just
another example of her trying to get
ready for 2020 trying to get those young
people in her base an area well shame is
very much under attack right now people
don't like shame probably because our
culture is is decadent and I'm not
complaining decadent cultures are a lot
of fun but the shame is getting short
shrift here isn't there
place for shame in society in
self-discipline in the way that you live
your own life isn't shame doesn't it
serve an edifying role at times it shame
is sort of how we depend on eternal
shame in both external shame to regulate
our own and that's something human like
for here all psychologists tell you
whether it be in a business setting like
a professional setting or whether it be
an online personal you know
person-to-person basis shame is what
prevents us from learning those around
us and from making decisions that are
best for our own interests and so when
it comes to you know with kind of what
amber was alluding to this you'll see
we're gonna see a lot more of this sort
of permitting you know behavior are
preventing anyone from engaging in
self-evaluation especially from the left
because you have a lot of figures who
tend to be on the older end of the
spectrum on the left side of the party
and they're really trying to appeal to
those young leftist voters and this is a
way for them to sort of show their
progressive chops we're not going to be
judgmental like the establishment
Democrats you know we're gonna be we're
gonna be free loving and more free
spirited and you do you and there's no
real element young man mm-hm
there's a right hypocrisy to it too
because these are the same people who
are using public shame to rid politics
in the media of all of these sexual
harassers it's the same exact tactic yet
they don't want to apply it inward well
this is the irony of cultural relativism
is at the the same people who are saying
that no culture is better than any other
culture and all cultures are the same
and how dare you assert cultural
superiority are the same ones who are
claiming that there's a rape culture on
college campuses if no culture has been
better than any other why should we
worry about a rape culture they can't
answer that because obviously we all
know that certain cultures are better
than others and and we wouldn't choose a
rape culture if if that were a reality
but it really it horses they're mellow
and it makes them get all judgy you know
you know what I mean man all right we
have to move on I need to get a little
judgmental on the fake news media
because we have another fake news
roundup today we did a whole episode on
News but then one of my favorite fiction
novelists Chris Chris Alisa and with the
Will Ferrell impersonator Jim Acosta
have really given us a great performance
today here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders
smacking around Jim Acosta star of
anchorman I would just say sir that the
journalists make honest mistakes
sometimes a lot of times you don't
there's a very big difference between
making honest mistakes and purposefully
misleading the American people something
that happens regularly you can't say I'm
not done you cannot say that it's an
honest mistake
when you're purposely putting out
information that you know to be false or
when you're taking information that
hasn't been validated that hasn't been
offered any credibility and that has
been continually denied by a number of
people including people with direct
knowledge of an instance this is
something that I'm speaking about the
number of reports that have taken place
over the last couple of weeks I'm simply
stating that there should be a certain
level of responsibility in that so what
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said there by the
way is 100% true now you might take
issue you say well we don't have
evidence that they're intentionally
cooking up stories but just to point out
her diction there she said either if
they're cooking up stories or if they're
running stories recklessly without
vetting their information because of
that or her statement is 100% true and
by the way there's plenty of evidence
that they're just cooking up stories and
intentionally pushing them this didn't
stop CNN's Chris ELISA from running this
headline today Sarah Sanders just made a
hugely offensive allegation against the
media now it might be offensive but it's
true it's a hit the reality is offensive
to the news media because they're
publishing fake stories there have been
three major screw-ups from the media
three major retractions in just the last
three days Chris ELISA I love that he's
the guy to run this story today because
he also he ran another story before the
election which was
titled quote Donald Trump's chances of
winning are approaching zero approaching
zero
that was Chris ELISA who says how dare
you say that we get stories wrong or we
recklessly run stories without the
corroborating evidence now amber the
mainstream media have been exposed as
hacks and liars and lying hacks is there
any way for them to recover their
credibility from here oh man it's gonna
be really really hard because they just
keep digging the hole even deeper no
they don't CN n of course had that faust
report on Friday about Don junior and
WikiLeaks where they got the date of an
email wrong the only thing about that
report by the way the only thing that
was wrong about that report was every
single thing that they said about it but
other than that the story was pretty
accurate I think yeah and they talked to
two different sources supposedly
independently who gave both gave them
the wrong date I mean it's incredibly
hard to believe I'm pretty sure what
happened here is that the reporters at
CNN basically had their own biases about
alleged collusion between Trump and
Russia confirmed so they ended up
running with the story even though they
didn't even see a physical copy of the
email or have independent verification
of size by the way do you know what I
think about that story I think this is
my conspiracy hat on so I'll put on the
tinfoil hat but having worked on some
campaigns before I would not be
surprised at all if it was a Republican
who leaked that info to CNN knowing that
CNN wouldn't vet the information knowing
that they would recklessly run with it
because it confirmed their biases we
know that the Trump administration did
this to Rachel Maddow over those tax
returns I wouldn't be surprised and if
so excellent job because you totally
exposed CNN for doing it it's just hard
for me to believe that Democrats could
be that incompetent to leak information
with with a completely wrong date on it
but if it was a dirty trick well done
a wonderful political trick to expose
those hacks at CNN arielle some of the
degradation of journalism has been
driven by demand so we want more opinion
in our reporting we don't just want the
facts facts are boring the clicks go to
saucy headlines and opinion journalism
that guy Dave Wiegel who
hosted that completely fake story about
Trump's crowd size he was hired to
provide facts and opinion and analysis
and whatever they know that they drive
this is is the way forward more opinion
or should the news media be sacrificing
some views to get less biased coverage
or more balanced coverage like firm in
the sense that you know there are if you
really have a strong opinion and you
don't think you are capable of producing
a report on an event without that
opinion impacting your report then you
should be an opinion journalist you
should write for a a political journal
that has a particular given slant there
are people that have plants and they
know this about themselves and so as a
result of that they you know they join
they become political journalists with a
particular slant and they join that
given publication my issue is that there
are plenty of wonderful journalists out
there who work extra extra hard in fact
I know them and I'm close friends with
them that work extra extra hard to make
sure their opinion doesn't infiltrate
their work however those people end up
being in the minority what I've seen
from mainstream outlets is that we have
too many journalists we're taking for
granted now they see themselves as sort
of what I understand is moral arbiters
they see themselves as firefighters you
see themselves as part of the resistance
and so everything they do in pursuit a
resisting Trump is somehow morally good
and so in that sense they don't they put
their resistance to trump and their
resistance of the GOP agenda as the
number-one priority as opposed to
reporting absolute fact what Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said it was not
necessarily incorrect because the line
between reckless reporting and
intentional misinformation is there but
it's very slim and it's also often
blurred right if you're driving at
extremely high speeds and an accident
occurs you are you no longer responsible
same goes for plagiarism um amber can
probably speak because she works
directly in the industry there are harsh
penalties for plagiarism and you know
that and sometimes it's not even
intentional but the punishment is still
the same because and that sort of goes
when I think about how we punish or how
we respond to misinformation yes they're
genuine mistakes but the result of
misinformation whether it's intentional
are just a matter of carelessness the
result is still the same you still
scribed false information and I know the
way to punish it I know my favorite way
to punish it which is to just keep
ridiculing them show them we showed this
clip yesterday from CNN where it looks
like journalism and for so long we
thought it was journalism we thought it
was news the guys wearing that nice tie
and his hair is combed and they're
speaking seriously they're probably
wearing these glasses you know and it
seems like a serious conversation but
it's not news it's just fabricated
nonsense and partisan hackery and I'm
more than happy to keep ridiculing it
bring it on baby it is extra cuff fa at
this time of year ladies thank you for
being here amber Athey from The Daily
Caller and Ariel Davidson from the
Federalist that's our show that's the
whole show today stay tuned for the
conversation with Ben Shapiro it's give
me a lot of fun and other than that I
will see you tomorrow come back tomorrow
we'll do it all again
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017